today on the matt welsh show we hijacked
the women's march this weekend to let
all the attendees know about my new film
what is a woman today i'll play the full
trailer for you we'll talk about why the
film is needed and what we hope to
accomplish with it also speaking of why
the film is needed three middle school
boys have been charged with sexual
harassment for misgendering quote
unquote a classmate and the media
vulture is immediately set to work
politicizing a mass shooting in buffalo
plus the mayor of chicago poses for
embarrassing photos in texas while
violence rips her city apart and our
daily cancellation an immigrant posts a
sign in his uber instructing passengers
not to ask him where he's from because
that question makes him uncomfortable
and sick we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
well you know leftists are raging more
than ever these days i thought it was
something to do with roe v wade nope it
turns out they heard about backstage
live and they're just terrified they
won't get tickets that's right on june
29th backstage live is back at
nashville's historic ryman auditorium
with me ben shapiro jeremy boring andrew
clavin and michael knowles to buy your
tickets right now go to dailywire.com
ryman last year jeremy said it we need
your help to fight back and save the
culture well together that's what we've
been doing we went toe-to-toe with the
government over unconstitutional
mandates and we won we threw down the
gauntlet to woke multi-billion dollar
corporations like harry raisers and
disney harry's razors and disney we're
boldly exposing the truth about fauci
the pro-choice movement and my personal
favorite radical gender ideology at
daily wire we talk a lot about you know
building the future with your help or
making it happen join us on june 29th
and let's celebrate these wins together
because they are all of our wins you
don't want to miss out get your bet your
tickets backstage live today at
dailywire.com
ryman
you know i used to see left-wing
protests and demonstrations as mere
annoyances you know events to be
dismissed and ignored basically but now
i see them as well still events to be
dismissed in a lot of ways but also as
opportunities and with feminists across
the country gathering together on
saturday for another women's march in
response to the impending end of row we
decided it'd be a perfect time to um
finally unveil the full trailer and
official premiere date for my upcoming
film what is a woman after all you know
i know from filming the documentary that
the women at the women's march are the
most confused of all about what a woman
actually is so uh this film should be of
great interest to them and very useful
to them
you know that time spent all the time in
the women's march you think you want to
figure out what a woman actually is so
figured this would be a good way to tell
them that's why we thought they would
appreciate it if we hijacked their event
to promote the film and as it turns out
they didn't appreciate it very much but
i still had fun and that's really what
counts so for the women's march in dc we
set up um these mobile billboards on the
back of trucks we had them circle the
march all day long
and the billboards asked a pertinent
question which is if you can't define
what a woman is how can you have a
women's march
good question and then of course we
provided the url what is the woman.com
to uh whether you could see the whole
trailer and become a member of the daily
wire i doubt we gained very many
subscribers from the dc women's march
but at least we gave them a question
that they could ponder and the same in
new york city where jeremy was nice
enough to let me use his jeremy's razors
billboard to pose the same question to
all of times square there was a women's
march in new york as well and then there
was the la women's march where we took
things perhaps a step or two
farther by posing the ultimate question
what is a woman
to the entire la women's march all at
once via message in the sky so a sky
writer wrote the question in the sky
over top the city while another plane
carrying a banner with what is woman
woman.com
circled around all day
now the funniest thing about this was um
the reaction from la residents who had
no context at all and perhaps didn't
even know that a women's march was
happening and yet emerged from their
homes on saturday morning to find this
question
emblazoned across the heavens as if god
himself was prompting them to think
about it i should also mention that the
hashtag
what is a woman was trending on twitter
moving up the trending charts quickly
threatening to overtake all of the
women's march hashtags until i posted
the picture of the skywriting at which
point the hashtag disappeared from
twitter's trending topics all at once
just like that never returned
apparently i think it maybe was it was a
bridge too far for the folks at twitter
many of them who live in that area and i
guess decided we were simply having
too much fun and we were
but trolling aside the important point i
think is the film which
again will officially premiere we can
finally announce on june 1st
you may remember that we originally said
it would premiere in may
but that was before we remembered that
june is pride month
and we simply could not pass up the
opportunity to unveil the trailer during
the women's march
and then premiere the film on the first
day of pride month it's just the
symmetry there it's it's it's poetry
it's poetic i think the way things work
work out that way
now if you think we went literally above
and beyond for the women's march you
just got to wait and see what we have in
store for for pride month
and the first thing we have in store is
the movie itself of course and for just
a small taste of what the film is all
about i'm going to play the full trailer
for you right now
if you're listening to the audio podcast
and you want to see the visuals that go
with this and trust me you definitely do
want to see the visuals then you can go
to my youtube channel or whatiswoman.com
after the show and check it out but for
now
here's a trailer let's watch
[Music]
what is a woman
can you tell me that
[Music]
well you're at the women's march you
must have some idea please if one person
could tell me what a woman is you are
not here for women we ask you to leave
what is that
i'm a husband i'm a father of four i
host a talk show i give speeches i write
books i like to make sense of things a
woman is not anything in particular
there is not one particular thing it
could be many things to many people some
women have penises right some men have
vaginas i like scented candles i've
watched sex in the city yeah how do i
know if i'm a woman that's a great
question you're not a scientist you're
not a gender studies major no how do you
know that you're a man i guess because i
got a dick
can a man become a woman
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that women only
know what women are are you a cat no can
you tell me what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is
i'm a biological woman
that medically transitioned to appear
like a male i will never
be a man and so they go on the internet
and they're told that all their problems
will be solved if they become a man so
you worry that there could be a sort of
social contagion element of this a teeny
tiny bit maybe it got me at 42 your
child doesn't have a
chance and you're affirming it with
hormones that have never been used in
this way puberty blockers which are
completely reversible completely
reversible one of the drugs used is
lupron right which has actually been
used to chemically castrate sex events
you know what i'm not sure that we
should continue with this interview you
don't want to talk about the drugs that
you give to kids or
how can they be removing the healthy
breasts of 15 year old girls there are
masculine girls there are feminine boys
what are we gonna do about that carve
them up how can this whole thing be
happening matt
i wanted us to have a safe place to be
able to talk about this part of me wants
to ask why you care so much i care about
the truth i care about children i care
about the women who are having their
opportunities stolen from them is it
transphobic to tell the truth the
interview is over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me they're fair i just
wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not gonna find out based on what
i'm saying would you ever want to move
to america
they said no
never
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed it a little bit
we'll see when it comes out
yes you will you will um june first
again is the premiere date if you have
been if you've been putting off becoming
a daily wire
member and procrastinating then what i
would say is that uh now is the time
and if you if you think about it all if
you have it in your budget become a
daily wire member or maybe get rid of
one of the 15 other streaming services
that you don't need and have nothing but
crap and uh go sign up for the daily
wire go to whatiswoman.com right now and
sign up or wait for that till after the
show and then sign up you know one of
the worst things about trailers is that
so often they spoil the film because
they show you all the best parts and you
see the trailer and you're like this
looks good then you go watch the movie
and you think well i already saw the
this is
the best part of the movie i already saw
that's not the case with this trailer
because the best parts and by that i
mean the most outrageous
shocking hilarious disturbing sometimes
all those things at once parts are being
saved for the film i can assure you of
that
what you saw there is just sort of the
tip of the gender confused iceberg
and hopefully it's enough for you to see
that though we're doing a lot of fun
trolling to promote the film
what is a woman is not itself
merely an exercise
in trolling i mean there's some of that
because it's me and i can't help myself
but the titular question is just the
beginning of the journey it's the door
into the gender ideology rabbit hole and
we dive into that rabbit hole and trace
it all the way to the bottom we stare
into the abyss and the abyss stares back
now i can tell you just from filming it
that
you know there are plenty of moments
when i had to stop myself from bursting
out laughing but also plenty of days
when we wrapped filming and i had
trouble sleeping at night because i felt
so unsettled by the things that we'd
seen the conversations we had the things
that we learned
there were a couple of times in
particular when
we talked about this when we were done
filming on these days it like felt like
we were
you know
glaring directly into hell or something
because in a way we were
now my hope then for the film is that
it will rip open the
curtain and reveal gender ideology for
was it what it is uh this is a movement
that has gripped hold of our culture
largely by deception threat and force
certainly not by making compelling
arguments
and convincing people
so case in point i have here the results
of a new poll from uh mclaughlin and
associates and summit.org and this shows
just how unconvinced most people are
so listen to some of these numbers
in response to the question
do you believe it's possible to
distinguish between men and women
and of course we mean like physically
of those who gave a response 93 said yes
of course gender ideology tells you no
you can't you cannot there's nothing
physical about someone that would tell
you anything about um whether they're a
man or a woman
93 percent disagree with that claim by
gender ideology
93
percent when asked about their personal
feelings about transgenderism only 36
percent said that it's a healthy human
condition the rest said that it's
unhealthy
though this is important
only half of those who said it's
unhealthy said they'd be willing to
speak up and say so the rest said that
they
keep quiet about it
when asked if elementary schools
should teach about sexual identity and
sexual behavior 28 said it was
appropriate
42 said it was inappropriate
30 said not only inappropriate but
dangerous so that's 72 opposed in all
and then should miners undergo gender
alteration procedures
90
against now
there are still more people on the
incorrect side of these issues than
there ought to be because there ought to
be zero
but this makes it clear that the gender
ideologues are in a small tiny minority
they have convinced basically no one
yeah that's that's another interesting
question that maybe we could do in a
follow-up poll
which is like whatever your opinion of
this right now
have you changed it over the last five
years
i'd say they've convinced no one because
all the people who you know whatever
seven percent who said that oh you can't
tell the difference between men and
women um most of them
these are the people making the claim
these are the actual gender ideologues
so it's not like they've been convinced
they haven't convinced anyone of the
rightness of their claims i guess i
should say they have however convinced
lots of people to be silent
they've convinced quote unquote lots of
people to just sort of cooperate and go
along
and that's why i'm hoping that our film
what is a woman
will not only expose the total absurdity
of gender ideology but also give people
the motivation
[Music]
uh the inspiration
to take a stand against it
publicly
and unapologetically
finally
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress helix
has
i got good news for you left the bedroom
and they started making sofas as well
they still make the great mattresses
they also make sofas they just launched
a new company called all form and
they're already making the best sofas
we've ever seen or sat in most
importantly so what makes an all form
sofa really cool for starters it's the
easiest way that you can customize a
sofa using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
the shape that makes it perfect for your
home and whatever living space you're
putting it in they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later if you want their
sofas are also delivered directly to
your door all form has simple quick
assembly no tools needed it's really
easy to do and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds a little risky
but you don't have to worry you get 100
days to decide if you want to keep it
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free and give you a full refund
but you will love it all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at
walsh to find your perfect sofa check
out allform.com
walsh
okay i want to go right to this because
speaking of why the movie is needed
right now let's go over to wisconsin
where
three middle school boys are facing
sexual harassment charges
okay middle school boys sexual
harassment
why because they quote unquote
misgendered someone
so here's the local news report let's
listen to
i received a phone call from the
principal over at the elementary school
for warning me letting me know that i
was going to be receiving an email
with sexual harassment allegations
against my son rosemary rabidu's
13-year-old son brayden is one of the
three eighth grade kiel middle school
students accused of sexual harassment
something she disputes he said he's
being allegedly charged with sexual
harassment for not using proper pronouns
i thought it wasn't real i thought this
has got to be a gag a joke
one has nothing to do with the other
according to the wisconsin institute for
law and liberty or will now defending
the accused students in march one of
their peers announced the pronouns they
prefer to be addressed as they or them
one of the alleged incidents brayden and
the others were supposedly involved in
happened in april she had been screaming
at one of braden's friends to use proper
pronouns calling him profanity and this
friend is you know very soft-spoken and
kind of just sunk down into his chair
and braden finally came up defending him
saying he doesn't have to use proper
pronouns it's his constitutional right
to not use you can't make him say things
some might say or think that you or your
son are against the lgbtq plus community
not at all not at all my my children
have been raised to love everybody
equally shortly after finding out her
son was being investigated rosemary
reached out to will title ix sexual
harassment typically covers things like
rape
dating violence
quid pro quo sexual favors right really
egregious stuff there's nothing even
remotely close to that alleged in this
case will says the school district's
policy doesn't cover the misuse of
pronouns and neither does title nine
okay so treating three middle school
boys as rapists because they wouldn't
use
the pronoun that somebody wanted them to
use
so we're ruining these boys
lives
because they wouldn't use the pronoun
please i beg you get your kids out of
the public school system
just get your kids out of the system
if it's at all possible for you to do it
if there's
if there's anything that you can do
there are any other options in your life
get your kids out of the system
because this but you know wisconsin
uh
it may be a liberal area particularly
where the school where the school is i
actually don't know i don't know whether
i don't know i'm not familiar enough
with the various areas in wisconsin but
the point is this is not um this didn't
happen in san francisco
i mean i'm sure this kind of thing does
happen in san francisco board that's not
what we're talking about we're talking
about wisconsin
um so it's
they could just simply ruin your kid
kid's life
if you don't get him out of the system
and there's an important point here also
just to uh
just
just to clarify
he was punished these boys are punished
not for using incorrect pronouns but to
make it all the worse here
they're punished for using the correct
pronouns
now even if they had used incorrect
pronouns like if they'd just gone up to
some boy who was a boy and called it
call the the boy a girl
to call that sexual harassment is insane
obviously
but it's even worse than that because
they used correct pronouns
they said what is objectively correct
and that is sexual harassment according
to the school
and the pronouns that were preferred
here they them
like that doesn't what if what if the
the kid said that uh identified with one
of these neo pronouns
you know the neo pronouns are just the
made up gibberish
zs i have the list here of neo pronouns
z zem zer i am air
v
is
nem ner
okay what if the kid had walked in and
said um i refer to me as knee nem or ner
now
what that's that doesn't i don't know if
that's those aren't words
i wouldn't even know how to use that in
a sentence because it's not a word it's
gibberish
but if the kids don't do that are they
sexual harassers now are we gonna lump
them in as rapists
um
but this just goes to show again the
point that we made at the beginning of
the show in the opening monologue
this is fear and coercion
that the gender ideologues are using
this is all they have
okay if we were to do a poll
on uh on this idea of people identifying
as they are them
i can guarantee you at least 90 percent
of people would think that it's
ridiculous
once again no one is being convinced
of the rightness of any of this
all they have is fear and coercion
and the good news
is that movements that rely and we've
seen we see so many historical analogs
here so many examples throughout history
and we know that movements that rely
entirely on on fear and coercion and
manipulation and force
they don't last forever
it's just it's not sustainable in the
long run now if you can actually change
people's hearts and minds
well now you have something that could
endure for generations for thousands of
years potentially but if all you have if
you're trying to force this uh square
peg into a round hole basically just
just just through force
it's not
it can't last forever
eventually people get tired of it
eventually people gather up the gumption
to
to stand and say no i'm not going to go
along with this
and that moment uh it has to be now now
is really the time it should have been
10 years ago
or before that
but it wasn't and now here we are in
this moment
and we can all decide
especially those of us and i'm sure most
people watching right now are adults so
those of us who are adults who are
grown-ups
we can decide if we're going to finally
take a stand and draw the line and say
we're done with this
we are not going along with it we are
not going to cooperate i don't care what
you do i don't care you can kick and
scream and cry you can call me whatever
name you want to call me
but we're finished if you're a man i'm
gonna call you a man and that's it
if you're a woman you're a woman and
that's it and those are the only
categories that i will recognize and
none others
you know the people in the poll the
the large preponderance who said that uh
yeah they know the truth but they don't
want to say anything
i get it i understand that you're afraid
um i understand it can be
startling and unsettling when you've got
a bunch of people screaming at you
trust me i know from experience
but if we don't draw the line right now
then then what
we're just going to pass it off to our
kids
are we just going to coast through the
rest of our lives and then turn around
to our kids and say uh well you guys got
to figure this
out because we are going to leave for
you in a completely insane society
where all semblance of of sanity and
rationality and truth has totally
collapsed you're welcome
figure it out
no we can't do that
i mean our kids uh aren't gonna
it's too much to ask of kids
you know in the trailer we we had the
the one line there from scott nugent
who's someone we we interviewed in the
film um
the line
you know got me at 42
your your child doesn't stand a chance
and
that's true with the qualifier
that if you just abandon
your kids if we as collectively abandon
our kids to this madness
then they don't stand a chance
they do stand a chance if we take a
stand and defend them
they have better than a chance in that
case
all right let's go to the latest on the
mass shooting in buffalo this report
courtesy of the daily wire says the
gunman who allegedly killed 10 people
and wounded three more inside a buffalo
supermarket saturday had been flagged as
troubled in his small hometown before
mounting the apparently racially
motivated attack authority said the 18
year old shooter allegedly live streamed
the murder spree on twitch um
so this is yet another case where
someone was known to authorities for
being troubled and having violent
impulses and uh but nothing really was
done about it until finally
tragedy strikes
authorities said the suspect who
allegedly drove some three and a half
hours from broome county new york to the
tops friendly market because it was free
frequented by african americans was on
the radar back home after allegedly
threatening fellow high school students
in june of 2021.
a government official familiar with case
told the buffalo news a school official
reported that this very troubled young
man had made statements indicating that
he wanted to do a shooting either at a
graduation ceremony or sometime after
state police investigated the incident
last year and the suspect was referred
for a mental health evaluation and
counseling
authorities said the shooter arrived at
tops friendly market at 2 30 p.m wearing
tactical gear and armed with the
rightfully shot four people outside the
grocery store three fatally before
entering
once inside the shooter was confronted
by a security guard uh aaron salter is a
former police officer
and
he
heroically uh
you know
attempted to defend the shoppers against
this gunman shot at him but he was
wearing the armor and then he himself
was killed sacrificed himself
the shooter shot eight more people
inside the store six of whom died
and then he was taken into custody now
a few things
first of all
as to the motive which you know we note
that authorities announced within
minutes of the attack
like right away they told us the motive
racially motivated white supremacist
whereas in say waukesha and with other
attacks like the subway shooting in new
york city
some of these cases they still haven't
told us the motive
but it's clear in this case that the
gunman in buffalo was racist targeted
black people targeted minorities
he was very clear about that
beyond that
and he has this whatever 180 page
manifesto
that uh
the media is
reading through and they're taking bits
and pieces of it uh because they're
trying to you know find a way
and they did it immediately of course
find a way to blame fox news even though
in the man like if we're if we're taking
this lunatics
quote-unquote manifesto
and and reading it and taking it
seriously
um
one of the things that he apparently
says in the man i only know this from
the from the clips and things that
people have put on social media i'm not
going to sit there and read 180 pages
of some mass killing scumbags manifesto
but that's what some people have done
especially in the media
because they noticed the political
opportunity and he says apparently in
the manifesto that he hates fox news
that's something that he mentions
explicitly
and yet the left has blamed tucker
carlson and fox news for this
and not just them
i've been lumped in too
because although
this
kid i was going to call him a kid he's
18 year old 18 years old this man's
ideology is a mess it's just all he's
again a lunatic
all over the place
um
he does mention
the so-called great replacement theory
and this is what's being this is this is
what they're trying to hang around the
neck of uh tucker carlson
fox news
really any conservative myself included
um
because tucker carlson and other
conservatives have in the past pointed
out
that the democrats have been very open
about the fact
that
you know they want to
have
they they want to
minimize what they call whiteness in
america
and they want to bring in voters
you know from other countries
they don't want voter id laws
you know they don't want to they want to
be able to bring in the voters and and
have them vote because they know they'll
be voting democrat
so they want to replace
especially white male voters with
voters who they think are going to be
beholden to them
now this isn't a conspiracy theory
um
there's nothing wild or
speculative about it
it's just a fact
and one of the ways that you know that
it's a fact is because the left and the
media the new york times cnn they've
been very open about it many times
so if it is a theory if the great
replacement theory is a theory
then it's a theory propagated by the
left
i mean they're the ones who go around
talking about this this supposed scourge
of whiteness and what are we going to do
to minimize whiteness
and how we're going to fight back
against whiteness
so they say all of that and then on the
right if we notice that they've said
that and we point out that oh they said
these things
then we're the ones somehow responsible
for a conspiracy theory
it's completely absurd and outrageous
and and worse than all of that because
in this case
they're taking
this shooting a very real event where 10
people were killed
and right away i mean they're not taking
any time to mourn the the lives lost or
anything like that just immediately
like tucker carlson's name was trending
along with the shooting right away
because these people they don't care
about lives lost
they don't care about the just untold
human misery and and suffering
that's now happening because of what
this scumbag did they don't care about
any of that
all they see is an opportunity
is a political opportunity
you know the thing is again if you're
gonna if you're gonna read through this
scumbags uh
manifesto
which i don't even know why you know as
as a as a rational sane person who's not
looking to play politics with dead
bodies
i don't know why you'd bother
but apparently he also said and this is
this is something the left is bringing
up because they're you know again they
want to they want to claim that he was
radicalized by the right whatever that
means
but apparently this guy says that um
around the time of the coveted lockdowns
he went online and it ended up on 4chan
and he was bored
and so he spent all his time online when
covert first started and that's how he
was quote radicalized
well there there's an interesting thing
there that that maybe we could talk
about
which is that you take this uh person
who is already
incredibly disturbed obviously
and then
you
block them in a home and just say well
you know just spend all your time on the
internet
and then this happens
maybe some connections we could draw
there
and maybe at a deeper level we could
really talk about is the uh
the nihilism
the empty emptiness
the the uh
inability to see to value human life
that is a real epidemic in our
country and whatever reasons this guy
gave for what he did
that's what lies at the root of it
just
nihilistic empty
do not recognize the value in human life
and despite the way the media portrays
it in fact there are shootings in this
country every single day
sadly and um
that's what lies at the root of most of
them actually
all the violence that plagues our cities
people just getting shot in the street
for nothing
what lies at the root of that
nihilus empty nihilism emptiness
people with no purpose in life
whatsoever
who take uh joy pleasure in causing
suffering
why is there so much of that in our
culture we talk about that at some point
no we can't because it's uh more
interesting to the left and more useful
to them to find a way to blame tucker
carlson
meanwhile uh speaking of exploiting it
so joe biden is going to be visiting uh
buffalo
on tuesday
which normally no problem with that that
makes sense president should if there's
a if there's a mass terrorist attack the
president should should be there should
make an appearance should go talk to the
to the victims absolutely
but you can't help but remember just a
few months ago
when there was a mass terrorist attack
in waukesha
when a guy drove through a christmas
parade and killed uh six people
including an eight-year-old child
and chose not to visit let's go back and
remember
uh and in fact we have the clip of when
the white house was asked about joe
biden visiting waukesha and here's the
the answer that was given listen
this administration is monitoring the
situation in waukesha closely it has
been revealed by prosecutors that the
assailant the assailant swerved his
truck side to side as part of an
intentional act to run over as many
people as possible six people are dead
some children remain hospitalized why
hasn't the president visited the members
of this christmas parade attack
well i would say first as you saw the
president convey last week our hearts go
out to this community to the people in
waukesha that we've been in touch
obviously with officials there and we're
all watching as people are recovering
and this is such a difficult time of
year for this to happen it's difficult
any time
obviously any president going to visit a
community requires a lot of assets
requires taking their resources and uh
it's not something that i have a
previewed at this point in time but we
remain in touch with local officials and
certainly our our hearts are with the
community as they've gone through such a
difficult time
assets and resources so they don't have
enough assets and resources we got to be
careful about the assets and the
resources to to send the president there
and so they decided not to now a month
after about a month maybe three weeks
after the attack in waukesha uh biden
sent his wife sent jill biden but chose
not to go himself never went himself and
never met with the victims families or
anything like that
because of assets and resources it takes
so long it's just so much of a trouble
meanwhile
within three days of the attack in
buffalo
uh dave got all the assets and all the
resources together
i wonder why that is
well we know why that is
he didn't visit waukesha because the
victims were white
and the terrorist in that case was black
in this case
in buffalo the races are reversed and so
he's going to
visit now we're so used to this kind of
thing from the democrats
and then ju them just being
vile
soulless
goblins
that that you know you almost want to
gloss right over it
but this is really extraordinary
to have the present united states who
chose not to visit
the site of a terrorist attack
because of the race of the victims like
he is he is
explicitly
maybe not explicitly because he's not
yet saying it but blatantly he is
blatantly choosing which terrorist
attack sites to visit based on the races
of the victims
and it's we're so used to it it's so bad
that uh when democrats do that now we
just say oh yeah that's the democrats
that's what they do
that's that's just their democrats being
democrats which it is but this should
not be normal
talk about things that should not be
normalized
all right now for some more uh
politicians embarrassing themselves on a
lighter note here's a lori lightfoot i
think we have
the tweet that she sent out okay here
she is so she was in texas
and she has a picture of herself
reading to kill a mockingbird and she
says in texas reading any damn book i
choose no banning of books or thought
ever
now first of all let's keep the picture
up there because
who reads like this
you're sitting on a stool there's a
bench right behind her
she's sitting on a stool at the
bookstore mask on facing the shelf
nobody reads a book like that is it like
is that supposed to be a thing that
normal human beings do yeah let me just
go to the bookstore with my mask on pull
a stool up no one ever reads i don't
think in history anyone's ever read a
book on a stool
but she's sitting on a stool facing the
shelf pretending to read
and second of all um just so you know
to kill a mockingbird that book is not
banned in texas
it's
uh
you know you can find that book anywhere
but the places that have tried to ban it
that's that's the left that wants to ban
it
because of the language in the book
and of racial insensitivity so if anyone
wants to ban to kill a mockingbird it's
the left
and third maybe you should be more
concerned uh mayor lightfoot
about what's happening in chicago
because speaking of mass shooting so
here's this is from the chicago sun
times it says five people have been
killed and 26 others wounded in
shootings across chicago since friday
now this was uh this was a report that
came out on sunday
so
that's over it's 31 people in it from
friday to sunday in her city who were
shot
and what is she doing she's in
a bookstore in texas
pretending to read to kill a mockingbird
maybe you should be focused on that
problem instead
the violence that absolutely plagues
your city
talk about nihilism emptiness people
with no purpose in life there's a whole
lot of that in chicago
people shooting each other for nothing
for no reason
while the mayor's often uh at a
bookstore in texas we're pretending to
read a book
uh more embarrassing moments from
politicians camilla harris
uh
we're just going to play the club i
don't think we need a lot of setup for
this let's just play it
that is especially true when it comes to
the climate crisis which is why we will
work together and continue to work
together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges
and to work together as we continue to
work
operating from the new norms rules and
agreements that we will convene
to work together on to galvanize
global action
with that i thank you all
this is a matter of urgent priority for
all of us
and i know we will work on this together
together we'll work together
so that when we're together
we'll be working
together
in a way that allows us to finally work
together
together
working together to build a future
together where we can finally
work together
on working together
camilla harris always trying to hit that
word count she's always gotta if it
could take any sentence that why say
something in
ten words if you can say it in 600 words
that's sort of the
that's camille harris's motto that was
my motto writing book reports when i was
in sixth grade that also is the way that
the vice president approaches these
situations we know the foundation of
this great country is the constitution
while the foundation of your family
should be your faith and your beliefs so
i have a serious question for you if
something should happen to you or your
spouse god forbid who do you trust to
instill those same core beliefs and
values in your children do you think
it's the same person that the state
would assign them to almost certainly
not if you don't have a will in place
you have no say in the future of your
children and if you're single you don't
think you need a will well you couldn't
be more wrong a will allows you to
establish advanced directive and medical
power of attorney so if you haven't made
one yet you're not alone but we're going
to make it easy for you at epicwill.com
when you use promo code walsh we're so
excited that epic will is partnering
with us
at the daily wire they're protecting our
staff
and our families let them protect yours
too epic will.com promo code walsh this
is how easy it is you can secure your
future in as little as five minutes with
a complete package starting at just
and when you use promo code walsh you'll
save 10
epic will.com this will be the most
important five minutes you spend today
again go to epicwill.com
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
all right uh austin says i was just
expecting this documentary to be like a
non-conventional comedy special but this
legit looks like it's going to be huge
for our
our culture uh that's what i was saying
it's it's there's a lot of really funny
moments in in the film
but
um
it deals with some really dark subject
matter and goes to some some pretty dark
places
so it's hilarious but not
at the same time
uh and you just have to see it to fully
understand and appreciate
let's see faith says you even went to
kenya slash tanzania for this this quest
is on to find uh the quest is on to find
out what a woman is for sure the messiah
don't play about gender roles that's for
sure uh they they really don't and um
like i said we
the best moments in the film are not in
the trailer and that especially is the
case with uh our trip to the to the
african tribe the messiah that was the
messiah tribe
and um we
i i went into we had a detailed
conversation with the messiah tribe um
about
the gender situation in the west and you
just have to watch it to listen to their
insights
um ben says matt planning a family movie
night for what is a woman do you think
it's appropriate for young kids my
youngest is nine absolutely not i have
eight-year-old twins almost nine they're
not gonna be watching this movie they
know that they know that daddy has made
a movie but they also know that they're
not allowed to watch it uh if you have
older kids like teenagers then that's
really up to your discretion i would
watch the movie first and then decide if
it's something that you think your kids
are um
old enough for and can be exposed to but
for young kids no um
we didn't we didn't make this
this movie was not made for young kids
in fact part of the point here is that
these are things that young kids should
not be exposed to
this is very much a movie for adults
about a subject matter that is
very much adult
uh
let's see
brandon says can we get a video series
of matt doing a play-by-play of a comedy
of errors involving failed life skills
as in today's cancellation followed by
his instruction in that skill
that's actually a great idea for video
series and i might steal it and the
thing is though also about about me
instructing in these life skills
um i am very deficient i'll admit i
myself i went to public school for 12
years so i i am also deficient in basic
life skills i am
just like your average american in that
way
but
you know i at least know how to cook
without burning down my kitchen
so
when when i i guess the point is when
we're in a situation
where i am instructing
people in life skills
then that's uh that just shows you how
how low the bar is that's a bad sign
nicole says i'd love to see you matt hit
the issue of men abandoning pregnant
women and never paying child support
what kind of harsher punishments should
be in place when this happens court
orders are a joke and what percentage of
women are living in poverty with said
children
yeah i'm fully on board with forcing men
we talked about this last week forcing
men to
take care of their kids take care of
their families
fully on board with that
um
absolutely the problem though is is the
conflicting messages in our culture
right now
because when the child is conceived for
the first nine months of that child's
existence
we tell the father this is none of your
business you have no power no
say to the extent that um the mother of
your child can kill your child and
you're not able to prevent it
and then as soon as the child is born
now we say okay you're on the hook for
the next 18 years
so there's a there's a real
contradiction here there's a tension
that just doesn't doesn't work
and so yes i think we should absolutely
require men by law as we do and maybe
these laws can be improved we should
require men by law to care for their
children
but that requirement and duty and
obligation and also privilege should
should begin not at birth which is an
arbitrary point but at conception at the
moment that your child exists
you now have as a man you have an
obligation
to care for that child and the privilege
to care for that child
that's the way it should work if our
laws made any sense at all which they
don't did you know that children can be
targets of identity theft just like
adults school or medical office data
breaches are common ways that their
information is exposed to cyber thieves
you can help protect your child's
identity by limiting how you share their
social security numbers
you can find safe locations for their
documents and also keep your online
devices free of viruses and spyware do
all of that
because look it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives your
personal information or your the
information of your kids gets exposed so
often making it dangerously easy for a
cyber criminal to steal your identity
protecting your identity can be easy
though with lifelock by norton lifelock
detects and alerts you to potential
identity threats you may not spot on
your own like loans taken out in your
name if you become a victim of identity
theft a dedicated us-based restoration
specialist will work to fix it so you
get plenty of coverage and protection at
every level of this problem nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
it's easy to help protect yourself with
lifelock identity theft protection
starts here join now and save 25 off
your first year at lifelock.com walsh
that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25
off
and also you know the women's march was
this weekend as you heard and in case
you were too busy enjoying your life to
notice there were a lot of people very
angry i don't want to misgender anyone
just angry people shouting incoherent
things about the right to murder
children in the womb at any point of
pregnancy if they so choose meanwhile if
they'd only stayed home and watched our
new daily wire original documentary
choosing death the legacy of roe they
might have actually learned some
relevant facts context and history that
they could have incorporated into all
their costumed chanting and graphic sign
waving but you can help us fight back
become a daily wire member and watch
choosing death the legacy of roe where
you can hear all the facts and all the
stories that the abortion regime has
suppressed for generations it's a very
important film you don't want to miss it
uh here's the trailer check it out
um many times when we
did this
as we started uh
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus it was too late to stop
[Music]
i was handing hush money
to women who we had left pieces of their
baby
we had put these women's lives in
jeopardy we'd put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for 800
and for a poor woman 800 is a lot of
money
i mean there have been so many moments
in the last decade plus of going
undercover in abortion clinics myself
and seeing
just heartbreaking things
women vomiting in the hallway of an
abortion clinic crying out in pain the
late term abortionists talking casually
about how they would literally leave a
born alive baby to die or if you deliver
the baby in the toilet then you pick it
up and stuff it in a plastic bag and
bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit they are being drowned
their necks are being snapped
it's it's happening more often than
people want to think about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women
and you're just you're realizing it
you're watching in front of your own
eyes play out america's greatest horror
story
which is
how we butcher children
in the name of choice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
the fight for life has all come down to
this moment so go to dailywire.com
choosing and help us expose abortion's
full gruesome truth right now now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today our cancellation begins with a
person whose name is a fun riddle for
someone like myself who infamously has
so much trouble pronouncing names i'll
take one pass at this and we'll go with
whatever pronunciation happens to pop
out the name is
raksha
vasudevan raksha vasudevan here we go
she's a writer for the new york times
and vice and she's certainly the kind of
person who would not be at all amused by
me making jokes about her
unpronounceable name in fact miss v as
we'll call her recently went viral with
a tweet about the harrowing challenges
immigrants face in this country she
posts a picture of a sign that her uber
driver had posted in his car and she
captions
seen in today's uber thinking of making
a duplicate to hang around my neck and
then the sign says which the uber driver
posted
dear passenger please do not ask me
where are you from the where are you
from question
conversation makes me sick frustrated
and uncomfortable thanks for your
understanding
now
until the same parts of twitter got a
hold of this tweet and started
responding which led miss v to deleting
it entirely many of the responses were
from other immigrants applauding the
uber driver and voicing their agreement
i think just one example should suffice
a woman named keon julie wang who
identifies herself as ex-undocumented as
well as a a litigator a vegan yogi and
an obsessive dog mom
all those from her directly chimed in
with this i once had a white uber driver
ask me this and when i said here he said
obviously we all live here now but where
are you really from i ignored him and he
asked again louder i said i wasn't
comfortable answering nor talking he got
very angry louder and insisted it was a
very fair topic of convo and why
wouldn't i just answer him it was so
scary i had to call my husband and keep
him on the phone the whole ride
psa to white people you are not entitled
to interrogate the personal history of
bipoc or any random human for that
matter the only time i welcome this
question is when a new asian immigrant
is looking to bond chat in a possibly
shared first language many koreans
mistake me for korean which i take as a
compliment i once got scolded by an old
korean lady in k-town for abandoning my
mother tongue
oh you see if you're white then you
don't have permission to speak to her
but if you're asian then you can
actually go up to her and scream at her
and she'll take it as a compliment
i can only hope that this woman's
husband explained to her that the uber
driver was annoyed because she was being
incredibly rude but i think we can be
fairly certain that uh she would not
have married the kind of man who would
tell her the truth in situations like
this or in any other situation her
husband is likely as neutered as her
dogs are we might assume but in the
event this this all is quite common
among young leftist immigrants i don't
say that it's common among immigrants in
general
most immigrants have probably never
heard of the concept of microaggressions
and once they do hear about it they
begin to second guess their decision to
come to this confused society in the
first place but on the left
it's considered a microaggression and
othering
if you say anything to a foreigner which
acknowledges that they are foreigners
they
don't want to talk about that aspect of
themselves
except for all the times when they do
want to talk about that aspect of
themselves in fact miss v's bio on her
website says this
born in india and raised in canada
raksha vasudevan is a writer and former
aid worker
that's the very first sentence of her
biography the first thing she wants
anyone reading her bio to know is that
she was born in india
and yet she doesn't want it to come up
in casual conversation
the self-contradiction is evident across
the board the left of course
relentlessly insists that we celebrate
immigrants minorities quote unquote
bypoc etc and yet at the same time we're
not necessarily given permission to
notice that anyone actually is an
immigrant or minority
they'll tell us that um you know that
they will tell us when we're allowed to
notice it and in what way and what we
can and cannot say when we do notice it
if we've been permission given
permission to notice it at all
we find a very similar dynamic with
sexual orientation and gender identity
because on the one hand
the gay leftists or the trans leftists
they go to extraordinary lengths to
advertise their lgbt membership and they
demand to be celebrated and worshiped
for it
but on the other hand
just because you're required to
celebrate it
doesn't mean you're allowed to ask them
about it
or talk about it or make note of it
again they will make the rules that
govern how you can speak to them or
speak about them and the rules are
subject to change
any time without notice
you must not only follow the rules
but figure out a way to read their minds
so that you can know the rules ahead of
time because you also can't ask them
about the rules can't do that you just
you just have to know you have to you
have to sense it intuitively
is this one of those moments when
it's a microaggression for me to ask
them about their identity or it's a
microaggression to not ask them
well you just have to you have to know
you have to read their mind
this is how they believe human
interactions work
and they're wrong so let me explain the
reality
and i'm speaking now directly to miss v
if she happens to see this
here's what you need to know
first of all when somebody asks you
where you're from
that is their attempt to be friendly
that's them trying to form a human
connection with you
that's another human being reaching out
to you a fellow human being in an effort
to relate to you and get to know you
if this irritates you or offends you
that's a sign of something wrong inside
of you
you're the problem
that's your hang up that's your issue at
best it's a pet peeve
but here's the thing about pet peeves
they're your problem
i feel the same about pet peeves as i do
about actual pets
you can have them lots of people do but
don't make them my problem
okay i don't care if you have a dog i
just i don't want to have to listen to
him or find his uh find his defecation
on my lawn
keep it to yourself
except in this case it's worse than a
pet beef
because it's ego which causes you to be
offended by basic questions about
yourself this is your own
weird little narcissistic impulse now
you may tell yourself that because you
don't want to talk about yourself in
these situations it's actually the
opposite of narcissism but that's not
the case it's narcissism because you
again like any leftist
you believe that you have the right to
set the rules for the conversation
you think you can and should control
what people say to you
you want to set the parameters not just
on what strangers say to you but on how
they perceive you
sometimes you want to be
be perceived as an immigrant other times
you don't
and you think the rest of the world has
to just
dance along to whatever tune you happen
to be humming at any given moment
no
that's not the world's responsibility
the responsibility in fact goes the
other way
it is your responsibility to suppress
and manage your personal hang ups and
unreasonable irritations so they don't
become a burden on other people
you must conform yourself to the
standards of a civilized society society
isn't going to conform to you
random strangers on the street they
don't know about your ridiculous pet
peeves all they know is that you're
another person a fellow human being
they might try to strike up conversation
because they want to know more than that
they want to connect with you
and in your case they'll quickly learn
that the most pertinent facts about you
are that you're rude unpleasant overly
sensitive manipulative and controlling
but at least they'll never find out
exactly where you're from so
you get your way in that respect i
suppose
either way you're still in the end
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire